[Music]
all right so let's do Russian hacking
and what I want to do is I want to put
quotes around Russian hacking because
we're actually talking about a question
of how we go about making sense of
everything altogether so Russian hacking
is not a an event as much as it is a
phenomenon that describes a very large
number of things that different
individuals depending on a particular
location in the social field interpret
differently so yes I think this is an
excellent example of this new emergent
mechanism how we go about doing social
control and it's interesting because if
you're looking at Russian hacking in
quotes from the blue church perspective
you're actually thinking about something
that isn't actually how it's working and
you're going to be making particular
mistakes so you will think I think I
mean certainly I'm defining a blue
church so certainly if you are in the
blue church my top modality you will
think that there is some kind of
hierarchical control structure with this
says small number of decision-makers we
will call them the Russians who are
principally responsible for the behavior
of the system under investigation so you
were looking for an expertise hierarchy
you know somebody who's in charge and
how their expertise hierarchy is
percolating downward in this downward
causation fashion to generate the
results of what you're seeing and that's
actually not an appropriate evaluation
of what's actually going on instead
Russian hacking and the degree to which
there is a specific understanding on the
part of the Russians which there
certainly is there clearly was the
phrase somebody used punching up and
they're clearly a dramatically more
effective right now than one should
expect them to be given their actual
capacity and power in the world because
of a higher quality strategy in this new
decentralized environment is I think
actually recognizing the obsolescence of
that notion of a top-down
decision-making framework where one of
the primary strategies is to find people
who are operating in that fashion and
throw effectively sand in their eyes you
know create obfuscation mechanisms that
cause top-down decision-making trees to
have a hard time either understanding
what's coming up
to them or having their actuation
potentials move down while
simultaneously being part of a very
large decentralized right not
centralized but in a decentralized
collective that is fluid and has an
upregulation behavior
all right so modulating things like okay
there seems to be an energy and a focus
in an ambient interest among some group
of decentralized individuals around
certain ideas how do I provide them with
an increase in localized energy or
capacity to enable them to focus in a
certain area and engage in activation so
it's more of a potentiation strategy and
much less of a control strategy and then
the other side of it and this is a deep
insight that I don't think anybody is
really grasping including myself is the
distinction between for example mimetic
warfare and information warfare and I
think many of the blue church folks are
particularly missing it on this so the
medic warfare is in many ways a legacy
of the kinds of stuff that television
does very well let me tell you a story
which is designed to create an effect in
you that will move you emotionally and
cognitively and that of course changes
the nature of memetic warfare changes in
the internet domain and we've seen that
broadly right kids on 4chan generating
images that flow out very rapidly and
are selected for almost ecologically but
there's also information warfare which
is the recognition that you can actually
use very high quality statistics and
very high quality precision to modulate
subtle causation in the environment so
for example I'll give you a sort of a
hypothetical let's say for example my
statistics told me that there was a a
sensitive point in one of the Florida
districts where the the likelihood of
decision making and say it was a 51/49
user we don't know exactly what it is is
open right the possibility space was
open and how that would play out and I
could generate some kind of very
lightweight intervention that would
increase the rate of traffic jams in
that environment but I say hacking the
stoplight so the stoplights are in a
differ
frequency and thereby decrease the
turnout and by decrease in the turnout
could probabilistically affect that
particular sensitive decision point
that's information warfare at a very
very high level and the whole point is
subtle very distributed highly
probabilistic it's much more like the
way that one might do a distributed
portfolio in finance as opposed to a
concentrated bet and that's another
piece of this whole story the kind of
thing that the blue church is very
challenged to do because it's
decision-making structure requires that
it make a small number of big bets but
that this new decentralized mechanism
can in fact make a very large number of
very small bets they can be extremely
fine-tuned I mean the point is that that
you don't actually have to take this I'm
super good at understanding how to make
complex complicated things which is the
old model and just throw out and
just see what happens and I'll throw
something out which kind of works and
somebody else will grab it and modify it
and it kind of works better and somebody
else will grab it and modify it and it
pops and then a whole bunch of people
will up regulate it all right so it's a
collective search algorithm with the
ability to modify because remember we
were dealing about symmetric and
communication so I can grab what you did
I can modify it and push it back out and
this enables a completely different
invention construction and dissemination
function mm-hmm I think that's an that's
fundamental like if you're not
understanding how to engage in that
strategy you're going to be selected
against increasingly over the next even
short period of time like three or four
years
[Music]